just to let you know that one person did
say naked attraction really yeah well
that's obviously my biggest fan
what is naked attraction
oh it's that show dirty
hi guys i am tom holland and today i'm
going to find out what the lab bible
audience thinks of me i'm very nervous
they gave me a clicker this time
what tv show would you most like to see
tom holland in could i make a cameo in
too hot to handle and run a what do they
call it a workshop
okay i think one would probably be
euphoria lots of people have been
talking about that
two would be
i don't know uh hawkeye maybe the disney
plush show and three i'm gonna go with
the new lord of the rings show
peaky blinders i actually auditioned for
peaky blinders and i did not get the
part next one is oh euphoria is two
okay well i got that right i got that
right what's number one i bet it's too
hot to handle that would be so jokes if
it is
i'm a celebrity get me out of here ah i
actually would love to do that i'd find
the eating stuff really difficult that
would not be fun i'll be alright in all
the small spaces and all that sort of
stuff i'd be good at the sort of
athletic challenges but i also have such
a short temper and i'm so impatient but
i think i would find some of the people
in there very irritating just to let you
know that one person did say naked
attraction really yeah well that's
obviously my biggest fan
what is naked attraction
oh it's that show dirty
what is tom holland's best feature oh
this is so embarrassing
my height
my broken nose my hair hair's a good one
i like my hair and i'm going to be
really lame and say my work ethic first
one is oh smile nice
personality i like that
muscles we all knew that was coming but
i didn't want to say that
and left toe
so we put these options in and they
decided which of these is the best oh i
see so i didn't have to come up with the
categories i've totally just gone off
the rails there
oh that's so embarrassing i reckon it
goes
[Music]
b
a
c d
b a
r oh dc personality is great though i
like that just to note that
left toe was more
more
than my muscles
i'll try so hard in the gym
i do have really oddly shaped big toes
though it's weird like in proportion to
the rest of my toes they're really thick
i like my big toes
who is better looking tom holland or who
do you think is the other guy
it's gonna be timothy chalamet i bet
you've put him up there no because he's
double handsome and i'd lose that one
jake gyllenhaal
he's also a double answer harry my
brother
i'll win that one seriously ah me
mark wahlberg that's actually a really
nice picture of me and that's not very
flattering light on mark there he's
handsome and in person but
i think i'm going to win this one
any words
enough said really
73
that's pretty brutal what question do
you think tom holland is most tired of
being asked well it would be are the
other spider-mans in spider-man will you
go to prom with me i don't know what
three is okay
how tall are you five foot seven and a
half is how tall i am proudly it kills
me every day so what is it like being
spider-man that's a great question i
love being spider-man it's awesome and
one
anything's in there related
if you had 24 hours to hang out with tom
holland which of these activities would
you do get drunk complete a thousand
piece puzzle together that's probably
quite likely i love doing puzzles have a
tom holland movie marathon with his live
commentary
now i do have a bit of a problem where i
will sit down with my mates and
everyone's like what should we watch and
sometimes i do really like to watch my
films i'm really proud of my work and i
think they're good films and i think my
friends would love to have a live
commentary of how i made them but they
never seem to go for it it's a real
shame stare into his eyes for 24 hours
straight i wouldn't let anyone do that
so that wouldn't happen
i reckon it's get drunk this is that
bible it's british
it's probably get drunk i'm gonna go
with a
cbd
[Music]
yes i'm so good at this game
which of the following things do you
reckon tom holland would most want to
buy a life-sized lego statue of himself
i already have one assigned tottenham
hotspur shirt i already have one an nft
crypto punk i already have one a
lifetime supply of jaffa cakes i'm
working on it
really you have all of them no i don't
have a lego statue of myself no no no no
i do have a signed tottenham shirt from
sony which i really like i got gifted
some nfts for christmas from a friend
this year and a lifetime supply of jaffa
cakes
i don't know
i don't know i don't think that's what
it is
and here you go to start thank you so
much
i do like jaffa cakes
wow that's mental have i said somewhere
that i really like jaffa cakes
i can't go wrong with the drafter cake
wow that is really good
it's double tasted
that is glorious
thank you lad bible for watching click
around me to do whatever it is they want
you to do i don't know i like american
football i just don't understand why
it's called football because they don't
use their feet yeah it should be
causally different maybe throw ball
whatever you want to call it throw it
you don't kick it
you do kick it yeah